as a couple I may have a Swiss passport
but at heart I've always been a big fan
of Germany what I like about Berlin is
that it's so multicultural but different
cultures come together here so it was
clear to me that if we left Switzerland
again then only for Berlin Berlin for me
my ego was born in Germany in 1975 to a
Swiss father and German mother but he
often spent the holidays at his
grandparents in the Swiss contour of he
bore after training as a chef ever
worked all over the world before
settling in Switzerland in 2013 he
became the chef de cuisine in restaurant
44 in the Swiss hotel in Berlin four
years later he moved up to head of food
and beverage it's important for me to
associate the recipes with something
they have to be tasty I have to think
that's something I like to eat as a
child and it always has to taste the
same like when a my grandma Lustig's
apple tart it's important to me that
when a guest dines here and then comes
back three weeks later it'll taste the
same that it'll be associated with a
nice feeling forbidden in 2016 the
mission our guides German Edition
awarded restaurant 44 of bib Kumar a
distinction for establishments that
offer exceptionally good food at
moderate prices the third floor terrace
offers a great view of Berlin's famous
kurfürstendamm Boulevard
[Music]
the restaurant serves a mix of modern
Swiss cuisine and traditional dishes
like Zurich ragout
[Music]
sewage net sodas I'm pondering
regu is an absolute classic what's so
swiss about it is that I use beautiful
veal tenderloin from a suckling calf so
the meat is very light and tender the
original recipe called for veal kidney
which you can order as well at our
restaurant to go with it no that's one
buttons of one skin but many people
don't like it and the sauce of course
gives it the perfect touch this mustard
can give you some touch of xeric ragout
is a classic Swiss dish it's always made
from veal the dish requires just a few
ingredients it's special sauce is made
from white wine veal stock and cream the
recipe for this zurich style ragout is
thought to have been first published in
a Swiss cookbook in 1947
[Music]
[Music]
the ragout is traditionally served with
Swiss potato fritters known as rusty
which are fried in butter
[Music]
the special ingredient in our Zurich
ragout is hand harvested pepper from the
maggia Valley in Switzerland to Chino
canton has a really fine taste and has
to be refrigerated can use a bit more
because it's not that spicy rather it
has a nice peppery taste it's simply my
favorite pepper I even go and get it
myself if I had to the Women's ensign
was restaurant 44 is located right on
the chorus and um a popular shopping
Boulevard in the west of Berlin but you
have to look up just bought the
establishment
the crew fearsome dam was once
considered the heart of West Berlin
after the fall of the wall the area
became less popular but that's changing
again
the West is livelier than ever
red weather weekend Samantha I remember
when I first came to Berlin I took the
bus somewhere and a young Berlin woman
got on with a currywurst then sat down
right next to me the ketchup got all
over my jacket and she said to me in the
Berlin dialect no you should watch out
and I thought then ok I've arrived
five years on and rhaegar really feels
at home in the German capital at
restaurant 44 he mainly uses regional
products as is common in Switzerland
begger and his team serve up no-frills
meat and potatoes cuisine of the highest
quality
[Music]
which offers continuity SWAT secure and
be seen mayor bling Bezier the
sunni-shia schnitzel until decision and
go